[Musique]
quand il est question du réchauffement
climatique
la majorité de la population québécoise
reconnaît l'urgence d'agir
fait rare la question fait même
consensus au sein des différents partis
politiques de la province
pourtant selon normand mousseau
professeur à l'université de montréal
nous faisons du surplace en fait engagé
à beaucoup au niveau québécois au niveau
canadien et on n'arrive pas à ça un coup
de pavant les cibles dont s'est doté le
québec sont ambitieuses en 2020 réduire
de 20% les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par rapport à 1990 en 2030 la
cible atteint 37,5 pour 137 est menée
pour ça c'est beaucoup
a on a vu que depuis une dizaine
d'années on n'arrive pas à avancer
sérieusement sur nos objectifs de 2020
donc on va rater les objectifs de 2020
de manière très importante et on n'a
aucune idée présentement comment on va
atteindre nos objectifs de 2003 aucune
idée on n'a pas de plein on n'a pas de
stratégie détaillée on a pas de mesure
on a pas de chemin on n'a pas de coût on
ne rien
pourtant au québec des dépenses
substantielles s'accumulent sans donner
les résultats escomptés
le premier avait eu 2 milliards
essentiellement livré aucune réduction
gala des terres ça a été un échec
presque totale donc on peut pas
continuer à empiler comme ça des
milliards qui ne livre pas sur nos
objectifs parce que ça décourage les
gens ça démobilise les citoyens c'est de
l'argent qui sert pas à améliorer notre
économie améliorer notre environnement
un mineur et notre santé
que faire alors parce qu'il n'y a pas de
cible au québec en développement durable
avec un groupe d'universitaires de
divers horizons
il lance une initiative pour repenser
l'action publique en environnement
donc on s'est dit on critique beaucoup
comme on n'arrive pas à avancer sur nos
objectifs environnementaux nos objectifs
de réduction de gaz à effet de serre est
plutôt que de continuer à critiquer
regardons ce qui se fait ailleurs dans
le monde il ya des endroits où des pays
avance réussissent à transformer et
regardons ce qu'on préfère au québec
pour copier ce qui se fait de mieux
l'initiative le climat l'état et nous et
eni donc en gros on envoie aussi
aujourd'hui d'avoir un texte fait tout
le monde le 12 avril dernier des
dizaines de représentants du monde
municipal syndicale de groupes
environnementaux et de partis politiques
se joignent aux experts universitaires
quelques approches adoptées ailleurs
dans le monde sont présentés on discute
notamment du modèle anglais sac ce match
comme ça en angleterre on s'est donné ce
qu'on appelle un budget carbone ou en
gros on s'assure de dire voici le total
des émissions dans ma société
voici je veux être dans deux en dix ans
20 ans et voici maintenant comment je
vais attaché tous mes fils d'une année à
l'autre pour arriver et ce qui fait que
contrairement au québec
l'angleterre a suivi année après année
le chemin qu'ils ont annoncé il ya dix
ans pour arriver à leur objectif est là
pour que cela fonctionne normand
mousseau observe une constante
ce qu'on voit ailleurs c'est que les
décisions liées à ses grands engagements
doivent être sortis d'émissaires de
l'environnement et ramener auprès des
100 d'audition économique
c'est un ange et qu'on a mais qu'une
fois qu'on a décidé d objectif c'est
maintenant de dire comment on transforme
notre économie sans s'appauvrir sans
perdre des emplois comment le transforme
pour aller vers une société meilleure et
c'est pour ça que nous on propose par
exemple les airs il faudrait prendre
créer un nouveau pas aux mines et
féministe du développement durable
simplement dont le seul rôle un peu
comme le président du conseil du trésor
le seul rôle serait d'assurer la
cohérence des actions à travers le
gouvernement il faut selon lui ramené de
toute urgence la science dans l'équation
la science est crucial dans la réflexion
elle n'est pas décisionnaire à dire qu'à
la fin on reconnaît que c'est aux
politiques de décider parce que quand il
s'agit d'avancer
on doit faire des déséquilibres prendre
des décisions et la chance ne permet pas
de décider mais elles permettent
d'éclairer les membres du climat l'état
et nous présenterons sous peu une
déclaration aux divers partis politiques
leur demandant d'agir sur les questions
environnementales
l'un des plus grands enjeux du 21e
siècle ici catherine mercier radio
canada montréal
[Musique]